[Music]
have you guys ever
ever killed a mosquito like just [ __ ]
like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] hate them
kill that [ __ ] how many do you
think you have garlic at least
500 in my lifetime really hundreds maybe
like good
i think i've only gotten two yeah the
same i think it's like two for me i
remember that
it's splattering and like the blood
splatters out my own blood and then i'm
like ew
doesn't work people be [ __ ] lying
when uh when it bites you and they say
you squeeze like it'll make
that was this idiot
but it doesn't work it was just one
person i thought it would work but it
doesn't
okay he said this idiot
[Music]
i thought it would work but it doesn't
work like that
misinformation i'm over here getting bit
i'm like [ __ ] what
you're saying you're leaving yeah and
then i got bit
and then the [ __ ] mosquito flew away
right and i was like oh
you just gave him free food you start
spilling out maybe you weren't strong
enough this [ __ ] mosquito was like
thanks just woke up even faster
[ __ ] you david
all right well this tweets went pretty
viral recently and
you know that trend like that meme where
it's like how it started how it's going
oh yeah that's one chick she ended up
posting
this there's a lot of mosquitoes how it
started how it's going and so
the first one is like bro i just called
a a caught a
macaw i'm not sure how to pronounce it
but she means mosquito
and then the next page is her collection
of she's a psycho [ __ ] past she has a
cemetery of them yes that's what people
called it in the replies too they're
like this is a cemetery what's that
black square
i don't know maybe she messed up it's
censored
oh [ __ ] it was violent yeah she used
glue she's like decapitated
she's glued no it's tape she taped
everything
she'll never get [ __ ] with again well
apparently she keeps getting [ __ ] with
you you should just open that book
everywhere you go
hey game of thrones is what they did the
[ __ ] head chopped off and put on a
steak yeah
same [ __ ] dude that was joffrey joffrey
whatever dude [ __ ] joffrey what's up
dude
yeah man that's [ __ ] crazy that is
some psycho
behavior it's like trophies for like
starts with mosquitoes but then it moves
on to
your animal sure sure
speaking of dicks speaking of dicks
people are in the replies on twitter
like this one person they they were like
this image reminds me of
this image what the [ __ ] who did that
i don't remember where it's from but
i've seen this image in the past all the
guys that she filled condoms of each guy
it's used condoms with photos of guys
that she [ __ ]
that that yeah likes her collection do
they go in there [ __ ] there too and
they're like staring at other guys you
guys know let me know in the comments
where was this from because i know i've
seen it in the past she's saving it i
think this is like
real obviously oh it's an art piece i
think it's something like that she wants
to have kids she's like
which guy do i want she can go back they
die
she has to refrigerate them right she
needs to freeze them
how come they all look dead though look
she murdered me maybe because she's like
i
[ __ ] is just a piece of their face
like a psycho this is just like this
like a photo like not all the condoms
are the same sizes
well that happens in real life some of
them get stretched out this [ __ ]
got a dung for days though my god
[ __ ] packing it's hitting the next
guy on top of his forehead
oh yeah this is forehead it's like this
part right here that should look like a
sausage casing
damn it does huh that's true
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is like this [ __ ]
like what else
what else is she going to be doing there
have been so many mosquitoes this year
like a ridiculous amount
we have a hanging zapper and when we're
hanging out outside i hear you go
this is whoops i don't like that you
know what doesn't have mosquitoes
vegas vegas doesn't do you know the
citronella yeah
we're all going david adios
i'll see you guys when i'm at this i'm
getting bit by mosquitoes and losing
your
come see me at the strip and get drunk
i'll visit i gotta stop drinking i've
been drinking way too much lately oh
really how much do you drink i got
alcohol
i can drink now you wanna drink with me
yeah but you can drink down you want
drink
i love this guy you got the alcohol i
got an alcohol did you just invite him
but then tell him to bring his own
alcohol
that's what brought up the glen finish
he was like this is not for you though
he's a kid that brings his toys to the
other kids house because get your own
toy stove
because i brought this to play with
myself
you can watch me share my immediately
i'm gonna get more
but at the moment this is the only one i
could drink i'm sorry bart i already
started without you oh yeah because
we're supposed to join forces yeah
weren't you gonna do it on a patreon
video i
am you guys drinking now i'm gonna do it
no not really i recently got way too
wasted so i'm not drinking for a while
uh that's why i always say it to myself
too but i just got smashed with [ __ ]
anthony he came on the podcast dude
we drink a little too much that [ __ ] i
don't know is it because he was sad that
he got number two
that was like one of the top comments
because this will roasted him years ago
it was such a good roast it's so [ __ ]
funny
it's so funny because he's so successful
it's so
funny have you ever collected any weird
[ __ ] no i'm not a weird person like that
[ __ ] weird because this kind of
reminded me of when i had that
disgusting habit as a child when i would
i
would put used gum on the back of my
headboard
and i would like just have a collection
of gum and then you would eat them right
and then like when i would run run out
of gum where like this gum that had in
my mouth ran out of flavors and i'd get
another gum and [ __ ] it it was all
filled with dust it was so gross
did you eat it yeah did it taste good
though
when you put the used one in because it
still had flavor so yeah
oh i chewed it till it was dead yeah
sometimes it'll just be like dead dead
and i'm like oh i can't chew this
anymore i'll throw it away oh you have
standards i'm sorry
i had no idea excuse me have you ever
tried that mexican
gum now she reads that they make like
little like little baskets and flowers
out of it
no no okay so this [ __ ] gum i don't
even know what they make it out of like
what type of gum or what ingredients
they're missing but they'll make like
little baskets or flowers and then what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
boil it and then it kind of like uh
comes undone and then you can eat it but
it's just so
[ __ ] hard and there's talk about
plastic no it's gum
that is not gum dude it's probably made
out of the same type of gum that
chiclets are made out of i'm sorry
because like two seconds they're hard
okay explain to me what happened again
so you have a basket yeah
it's gum and then they melt it down at a
thousand degrees fahrenheit that's how
they do it
and you have to boil it to chew it yeah
to soften it up that's a mouthpiece
i was like i'm so confused right now
yeah it's the wildest [ __ ]
flavor is that at least there's no
flavor oh nothing i don't think that's
gum i think that was a toy
and then you were just chewing on a
painting now i gotta find this [ __ ] can
you guys please find it for me please
i know i'm not crazy for a hug her life
was really hard dude
get up get up she was like well you know
this gum right it's
shaped like a little car and it rolls on
the table and then when you boil it you
chew it it's like no that was actually
just a toy car dude
this gum that comes as a gi joe you
gotta melt it down that's what i'm
saying i don't know what's going on
she's gonna go to someone's house oh you
got gum my barbie
my gum was shaped in the sink of saint
maria and then we light it when people
die and then we chew it you know when
your parents buy furniture but then you
boil it and you chew it it is gum what
the [ __ ] is she talking about right now
i was hoping my [ __ ] mexican
connection looking it up right now it
doesn't exist
what is it called basket gum yeah
mexican basket gum
chew poor people mexican gum okay i put
i googled mexican gum shaped like
flowers that you boiled nothing okay
well he got the boil
you know what came out it came out it
says
just an idiot right i gotta look it up
keep talking i have a picture of jio
i know just you like this google how
many mexicans have ate furniture before
yes
hold on the thumbnail the thumbnail
looked like it was but now i'm oh forget
it
okay forget you guys please help me
please it just looks like dirt
chewing gum crafts what is this oh crap
is it like this
yeah yeah that's it that's the
[ __ ] gum
that's what i'm talking about god please
let it beat them
i don't think that's the problem i mean
they no they labeled it is this like
mexican origami or something
it's gum like gum is like five cents
chewing
gum and then it looks like ribbons
but you know regular gum is so cheap and
it
you can't get it here yeah they have
like pretty flowers i mean she just
built
i need to see her chew it first and it
smells really bad why would you chew it
it looks like they'll do a different
[ __ ] like that wow she's really cool
that's the gum i'm talking about i've
never seen this do you actually chew it
you want to know something so funny like
the only way we found this is we found
footage from 1862
the first gum ever made my god
that's made out of gum huh how much i
love gum that i would chew
any sort of gum wait so you chew it and
then you form it into like flour no you
don't chew it no no
no no i don't know how they make it into
the flowers and do all that but you can
eat it after
why do you why do you like gum so much
what's with your obsession with gum i
don't know
just growing up i really loved gum and
like my mom always had gum
make you feel cool no i just like
chewing it
bubble yum was pretty pretty good big
league chew
or that one it's like you ate plastic no
it was the worst because the
the flavor didn't last a long time okay
that's all juicy food the flavor didn't
last but it was good
or the zebra gum tastes the best but it
goes away
dude i would chew gum so much it would
melt in my mouth that's happened to me
before you have a lot of issues you're
like just melting gum in your mouth
you're sticking it on the wall
what else did you do i mean that was
around that same period of time i just
like my shoes out of it
gum forever no i didn't make shoes made
chews out of it
mexican chews yeah that was the only
weird thing i think i ever called that
thing deeper because that's [ __ ] nuts
no that i collected
that's something crazy you chewed gum
you stuck it on your wall
i was like i was nine two i don't give a
[ __ ] what are you
saying right now that's weird and your
mom walked in she goes i know
it's another monday and she just walked
out it's another gum dance
no i definitely know it was [ __ ]
weird i'm not even defending
what did your like mom say about it
she's just like i don't
even recall her even noticing that i did
that so i don't know that's the reason
why
i was she was neglected neglected child
that's why i had to [ __ ] be addicted
she's like well my mom never came in my
room
[Laughter]
[Music]
ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you